I don't think you've ever looked better first of all.
I love the full beard, I don't think
I've ever seen you with a full beard.
Beat it Drew, this came here in the pandemic
and Jackie's been wanting me to shake it ever since,
she hates it, just for the touching of it all.
The kid, Sonny runs up to me,
grabs it, pulls it, nobody likes it.
You know the reason women don't like beards,
is 'cause every time you kiss them, we get chin acne.
(laughing)
Yeah, no that makes total sense, total sense.
I actually without the beard, tend to spread
acne everywhere I got.
(laughing)
But I will say this, I was watching Jackie
in The Wrong Missy, which by the way,
was just exactly what I needed during the pandemic.
I loved it so much, like Lauren Lapkus.
And I forgot that she's in Blended.
Like I was freaking out,
like this female comic is bringing it.
Yes, yes, she kills it, she did kill it in Blended.
I remember when that thing blew up in her face in Blended.
I kind of had like a star struck moment
where I was like, oh my God,
we got to do like a movie with her,
'cause I think she's a level 10 beyond, in The Wrong Missy.
But what I really took away from The Wrong Missy,
is how hot Jackie looks.
Jackie stepped it up, she actually didn't step it up,
she always looks good.
Jackie had two cheeseburgers last night
and lost two pounds while eating the cheeseburger,
I don't know what's happened.
I don't know but some people have all the luck
in the metabolism department, I'm not one of them.
I have the metabolism of a sloth on Valium.
(laughing)
Well Drew, there's a reason
I haven't taken my shirt off in 14 years.
We'll never stop eating.
The last time we hung out was at a Chinese restaurant
and you should've seen the spread.
Crazy.
It was epic.
That was the best night Drew, man, your speech.
Drew gave me an award, to be nice,
they gave me a nice award and Drew did the speech,
and winged it, I hadn't thought about it before,
but just went up and talked,
and it was two minutes of the sweetest.
The phrasing, everything you did,
and I literally Drew, was tearing up and my lip was shaking,
because you were being so nice to me.
And I don't cry, I don't cry.
Jackie always says, what the hell's the matter with you,
your eyes never tear up.
Not that I just stay straight, I'm insane,
but you were making me cry.
And when I went on stage to take the award
and I saw you and you just got,
I couldn't stop having that shaky voice.
Good, that's what I wanna do,
I wanna do it to you and make you cry,
'cause I love you so gosh darn much.
I took this this morning to let you know,
this is the birthday flowers you got me, can you see that?
Finally, 'cause they went to the wrong address.
Whatever, it's in my bathroom, it really is powerful.
Put it to you this way, all I smell are those flowers
in my bathroom, that's a powerful flower.
Well you're welcome Jackie.
(laughing)
Anyway, I love you.
Oh hey Drew, congratulations on this.
This is the greatest, you're gonna make
the whole country happy, showing CNU everyday
like you do for all of us
when we're making a movie together.
Drew comes on a movie set, the entire mood changes.
People stop working, they just look at her
like oh here she comes, the sweetest girl.
And you go so far out of your way
to make everybody feel comfortable
and loved and important, and you're being truthful.
It is a team when you're making anything,
like on your show, I'm sure everybody's loving you there,
and I'm sure the whole country's just gonna really enjoy
being with you everyday buddy.
(upbeat music)